this video is brought to you by
expressvpn and Shopify people more on
them after the
reaction what is going on there citizens
of the reject Nation it is time to watch
the theatrical cut we will not have a
discussion as to whether or not should
they have done this and just released
the director's cut who knows John how
are you I'm excited for the Netflix cut
of the eventual SN cut all righty well
that's what I like to hear ladies and
gentlemen it is a chaotic schedule
around here so we got to get swing on
action but let us know in the comments
below did you like Rebel Moon did it
live up to the hype are you excited for
the director's cut should have just
released it I'm just saying should just
don't go with that but let's find out
going with an open mind anyway leave a
like on this video ladies and gentlemen
also be sure to subscribe click that
notification Bell get notifi when we got
something that comes up on this channel
that might peek your interest cuz we got
a few to wrap up before the end of the
year thank you to all who have been here
with us also thank you to preer for
helping us edit down the highlights on
this bad boy you guys have been an
awesome team thank you so much and
lastly m massive thank you to all who
have joined us at our patreon page one
of the best ways to support the channel
undoubtedly full anth reat and watch
along where sync up with your own copy
of Rebel moon with us that is available
for super sexy rejects we also cover
several things over there with
highlights and watch songs included
let's get into action
people on the mother World 1,000 Kings
ruled unchallenged in succession I love
his voice so much in the Royal bloodland
lust for
power they consumed everything upon
their planet of course endless expansion
the realm marched its armies into the
vastness of space conquering everything
in its path the Empire that didn't look
suggestive at all until the treachery of
an assassin's blade struck down the king
and queen oh fascinating in the chaotic
aftermath of the King's death several
conquered planets on the edge of the
mother world's reach began to whisper of
Revolution a rebellion a a senator named
belisarius used the opportunity to seize
power declaring himself Regent Don
Bellisario Crush without Mercy those who
would call themselves Rebel
Rebel damn I wonder if Anthony Hopkins
is a character or is he just a
it's a good question maybe he's a
Transformer damn that was a beautiful
visual sure we'll be saying that quite a
quite a
bit
wowe what a
horizon it's always a struggle to be a
dirt
farmer come on Ray Luke get
going save tattoo you know that is that
a a specific type of animal or is that
just a headpiece for a
horse feel Mother Nature's banquet her
Bountiful
Harvest oh my God Zack Snider
hey I think that is alien horse
creature
cor the legend of Kora Den was asking
where you were he and his brother got a
big snow elk he wanted you to see it
before he dressed it why was he asking
for me because he's into you I I just
thought I just thought yeah you
thought whoa look at the waterfalls in
the background dang oh wow yeah this is
aesthetically gorgeous for sure kudos to
the production
team my people oh my God it's it's it's
Cory stall yeah gods of the Harvest
demand a tribute I volunteer for we all
know it is the thrusting of hips and the
loud sounds of pleasure that summon the
seedlings to sprout you're talking about
banging getting going for the Harvest
for the very food we eat yeah
populate for the
gods much better than ritual
sacrifice a she didn't go to harvest I
like how the door looks like ancient
wooden but it opens automatically have
you thought of a more permanent
relationship monogamy exists across the
Galaxy I know that he's aable to the
idea he's ask me himself it's easy
between us does it have to be more than
that you know a friend with benefits is
cool and all but you got a mantle to
uphold that would be your last step to
becoming a full member of this community
to be a wife that would be the last step
you'll get your green card if you marry
him the two seasons I've spent here have
given me happiness but understand I am a
child of War truly love and be loved I I
don't know if I'm capable of either just
got to find the fire within this damn
good
television
I was taught that love is weakness I
don't know how that will ever change it
it won't give up now I don't know
anything about her character
yet or do I know everything about her
character
yes all right I'm a sucker for romantic
flowery language like that we're just
like just laying it all out on the table
for me but you could tell it's like it
sounds pretty you're in love with your
own dialogue and I like
it I'm aware it's like heavy Exposition
but
whatever I just watch Christ Christmas
Hallmark movies and it's it's better
than that night and day now if Zack
Snider made a Hallmark movie oh my God
that'd be
great SL sh the
seats no it's a
symbol oh my God what a great hammer
[Music]
ooh God man hey he only been there for
two seasons who gives you the
right suit up bumblebee her yellow
jacket you you get it what do you think
they want everything I don't care what
the potential upside might be a warship
hanging over our land cannot be good we
have 3 days until they descend maybe we
can get to better price from our friends
in low orbit there rather than having to
deal with the Cutthroats in Providence
selling our grain to God Only Knows
Providence ironically named I wonder
what they would say if they found out
where our excess went last year just say
we ate it C I don't have a sign only
this community that's my only loyalty
can't imagine what your Arc will be
start by showing them Goodwill not fear
that we are their Partners not their
adversaries did you say partner gunar I
did I did is that a problem yeah man
come
on it purpose is to destroy to subjugate
to enslave even even I know come on man
just look at that
ship they're
coming the British are coming xre X3 TIE
fighter or a Speeder
Bike damn boy great touch on the birds
and the Brie flying at the camera the
scope call me delusional I think so much
emotion is evoked from there's a way to
derive emotion Beyond a script oh sure
you can derive emotion just how
something is visually making you feel
you know and they call that Cinema like
this feels like a a graphic novel so far
we're only like 15 minutes in but it
feels like a graphic novel absolutely
does I'm having fun so far I mean we're
still in Act One hello I am cindry
father of this Village you may call me
Daddy I'm Admiral Atticus not loyal
representative of the slain King I
welcome you to his warm embrace give him
a
hug that was the least expected
gesture that's a very long hug and may
have a glass of your delicious
milk
uh-oh we've carved out a simple life
here you're marked in the director's cut
he paused and had like 30 minutes of
conversation with her yes was so much
Nuance you understand the feeling of of
like a father that need to feed your
children yeah of course he does I was
hoping that your land and the people of
velt might be able to help as we search
for a small band of revolutionaries
hiding in this very system he is Hans La
yep we are humble Farmers far removed
from the politics of the mother world
the rebels we seek have been attacking
our supply ports led by a woman named
Debra
BLX the captures inevitable however it's
taken longer than anticipated we found
oursel admittedly low on stores
inevitable may have heard an army runs
on its stomach that's true that's what
Rob Zombie says John Carpenter before
him was thinking of a partnership where
you supply us with food and exchange
your compensated that let's call it
triple market value shall we with that
wind for whe by plenty of Harvesters
robots and won have to do this difficult
work by hand two darios in the same
scene it's crazy is Cory going to die I
think he going die and then the people
of velt will rise up you see the land is
Rocky and yields barely enough to feed
ourselves so it is with sincere
apologies that we must decline the offer
grateful for the presence of such a
benevolent and Powerful
protector that sounds very sincere yeah
no
Surplus n at all whoo look at that
glisten in his eye what the hell's going
on there got somebody off camera shining
a light who's the man or woman among you
who oversees the
Harvest uh-oh there must be one of you
whose thumb is greener than the rest
someone don't do it that just me yes I I
oversee the Harvest God damn it Gunner
just trying to understand how I could be
so wrong about what this land could
yield that's all you better make up some
good buddy cindry our beloved father is
always looking out for the welfare of of
our
village that's you keeping reserves in
case of famine or drought which as you
know is the responsibility of a leader I
would not have said that terrible line
but we have been lucky these last few
seasons uhoh and our Surplus has been
more than we can store uh-oh dude chance
that we can spare a small amount
depending of course on the scale of your
needs good what are you doing man it's
always wise to hold some in reserve
isn't it
father y yep oh dude yep yep yep why you
should have me believe this land could
barely yield enough to feed your people
no one is trying to mislead you cnry
simply has a slightly more conservative
view on reserves than I do I'm a liberal
but we're both excited about a possible
partnership he said partnership father
who is this exactly um it's of no
consequence I have been empowered by my
people to speak for them this getting
complicated you would be wise to ignore
him well a rift yeah yes it's not quite
the idilic community I'd first seen
offer you some advice when dealing with
subordinates who need to be kept in
place he kill them I'm a smack a gentle
reminder of just how those with power
deal with those without ohoh I'm I'm
afraid for her
man so he going to give her the Beatdown
y who's this villain he's good that's
green that's his name yeah I I let me
show you what I mean n it's a ploy he
knows he can get information out of him
come
on
oh yeah oh damn you called it
ooh oh my God you should have
listened did you do oh dude what can I
expect my Harvest I mean gunar you say
the stupidest [__] dude I said tell me
partner when I can expect my Harvest
woof n nine weeks
very well in 10 weeks I shall return and
you shall have my 10,000 bushels
prepared for my ship we barely produced
12,000
bushels I I don't understand what you
want you should have thought about that
man you're so frustrating man why is
this Gunner guy such an idiot I don't
know it's like really obvious a second
he started opening his
mouth everything he says just like dude
what's wrong with you he's never left
this Moon he knows nothing about
military
force hello
everyone oh it's good they're going to
have them to look after that's good whoa
oh sweet oh it's the new Tesla Optimus I
am JC 1435 of the mechanicus military
that's Anthony Hopkins it is my honor to
serve he's the narrator of the story
too
no
dude what a waste
thank
you bet this dude's even more messed up
than the other guy he's just pretending
what in the name of the old gods are you
looking at I'm sorry I was just waiting
to see if you needed some more water
some more
water it's a Jimmy
man I don't know we had any of those
left oh that's what they're called a
Jimmy yeah all right careful the
ground's uneven till you get to the
bridge thank you private Aris but I
believe I can manage you know I wouldn't
fight anymore boss what do you mean they
won't fight anymore expire droids once
the King was killed they just lay down
their weapons and refuse to fight a new
king must Ascend no matter what I do he
doesn't fight
back dude careful with that stuff you
stupid machine I'll do you to scrap you
dumb [__] hear me oh uh oh he in
me dud whoa damn why are you abusing
this pacifistic Droid I could kill you
right now no one would K when to
die come on boy do you want to
die I sa enough get these crates into
that house now tonally it really rides
the line of an rated movie get up go to
the river clean yourself get back to
work get back to work wor your [__]
that includes you Marcus now why don't
you shoot some of your other cohorts
here thank you that is kind you're a
soldier long ago do you mind I'm Sam God
that does look
incredible lighting too do you know the
story of our slain King and his
beautiful daughter the princess Issa
Issa Ray well you remind me of her
really and even before she was born I
and my brothers pledged everything we
were everything that dwells inside this
metal skin to fight in her name he will
be loyal to you cuz you look like her
that she as prophesied had been born of
flesh and blood into our world I felt a
great warm and trusted that she was to
usher in a new age of peace and
compassion this robot's projecting on
the day of her coronation she along with
our honored king and queen were
assassinated in Cold Blood by those they
trust it most at to brute I'm afraid our
compassion our kindness a very Joy died
with that young girl I like the
inclusion of this artificial
intelligence a lot it was very emotional
and
devoted you
know oh now you can go to
Coachella a little bit of spirit coming
back like I've always thought in Star
Wars especially when it comes to droids
of what is the discussion around what is
the life around a Droid I'm really kind
of getting that desired effect here yeah
more than just like AI robots and what
do we do about them like this like it's
a real feels like person yeah yeah yet
they treat him like he's disposable how
about we bring in the crop and we fall
on their Mercy they wouldn't be able to
kill us they would need us he's right
farming that is our skill that they
cannot there are no other farmers in the
whole Galaxy we can appeal to those
gentlemen in The Granary appeal to their
Humanity oh why areio always running
away you must face your trauma in your
past become the leader of the resistance
become the child of fire when I found
you in the records of that shap I
considered leaving you oh my God just
keep laying it all out for me this is
drama but do I for a moment regret
bringing you into our lives I do not
just tell me everything you've become a
part of us and yet now you leave when we
need you most one of us one of us what
if we did fight not only us but others
who who else do you think come here and
fights others that have reason to hate
all that the mother World represents a
rebel alliance what if you could find
the Warriors that Noble seeks The
Outlaws to fight alongside us if I give
them hope they fight and surely lose
they need a new hope look I'm really not
just giving it a path
and maybe it has something to do with
seeing such terrible R Tomatoes of yes
are there things that remind me of Star
Wars in you're of course a farmer girl
whatever and D yeah absolutely I'm
saying that specifically in the Star
Wars aspect side of things we are really
staying here in the farmer lifestyle
side sure really living in it and how
poor and hard it is to live like this
yeah agree and before we've get into any
big rebellion action as opposed to like
let's hurry it up we got to get to the
exciting stuff yeah so I'm like I kind
of appreciate it yeah it's it's
breathing for what it
is uhoh this is
Icky oh no you can't ignore that come
on and my
axe I've attracted
her we shared eye contact I have romance
with
her oh yeah let's go let's
go I make you watch every day as she
turns from a f
girl I really hope this sequence doesn't
get any longer in the already cut yeah
that's all this all sounds nice but
you're not going to do anything not
until I oh my God this is PG-13 movie I
that is very harsh language Jesus Christ
maybe it is that thing where they cut so
much out of the rated that they were
like oh we'll give you the PG-13 cuz
it's way less harsh than it was
before stop
Des perfect ah don't make her cut
showing the ugliness of the soldiers I
yeah sure it's like plot-wise of a
derivative but still I don't know it's
kind of like the R-rated version of
it let's go let's go all take the gun
she going to leave the
canoli
yeah nice oh those ringing
sounds oh God yeah I got chills yeah
damn boom
boom pocket
sand I like their Blaster sound effects
[Music]
ah woo
oh
damn man man knows how to do action in
slowmo slow and
slower right in the
footo nice man
oh
nice oh
yes oh riding the juggler and nothing
came out the back is that what you
want Han look decided to join us Rise Up
Robot come on
Hopkins rise up robot no in your flower
crown
yes he has hostage the girl that reminds
you of the girl who died kill
thiso oh wow good shot it's good to have
k2so on your
team what have I he looks what I done
somehow this is also the first time the
robot has witnessed these soldiers
behaving this
way
no we're going to have to fight hell
yeah we are you put that on them they
didn't want to fight I feared it could
be dangerous that is an ornate gun where
will he go General named Titus once a
hero of the realm who turned his own
forces against those of the mother world
oh cool where's he last I heard he was
still out there somewhere that sounds
like a very
vague it's okay we got our mission
gunar last year in Providence you sold
grain to the
resistance I thought you had no Scruples
man I meant a man there who introduced
me to the insurgents the blood
axes then you'll take me to him of
course I will I don't trust you Gunner
yeah he going to betray you I don't
trust
you does have a very interesting look
with these
lenses said they created again Zack
Snyder and his team made special lenses
for this movie they have all kinds of
distortion like vignette style around
the frame how can you know they will
destroy us when they first came to my
world I was 9 years old they never asked
for anything
flashback only the loss for Destruction
when the gun was smaller oh commanded by
a young General named alarius who
relished the Ecstasy of combat there are
so many names to keep up with I know a
little too much it wouldn't be a classic
Sci-fi epic without him but he had
served only to enrage the young General
and gave him provocation to take take
out that anger on the innocent yeah
Display of
Power I found myself face to face with
belisarius oh damn Who Loved commanding
his troops not from the cunning Tower of
his ships but on the battlefield but on
the battlefield itself as a real
leader is he going
to
wow
[Music]
huh basar has killed my entire family
and took me with him I don't know why he
spared me why of the hundreds of
thousands that died at his hands he
chose me to live does the red light mean
the gun is out saw something in me I
suppose someone's sharing his pain he
can condition you cuz you were Innocents
and corrupt you and for 5 years I lived
on that ship with its soldiers who were
my only family
no
softness only the heart lessons of
War facts look flipping beautiful man
and I was his child I was his prode I
was his student and I loved it daughter
of a decorated Commander friend to the
king and the royal family living a life
of privilege Cario it
is
wow oh so she knows exactly what they do
because she was raising the
evil uh-oh uh-oh you're marked scar guy
someone we would defend with our lives
when the politics of expansion became
too abstract and the why of the conquest
was lost in the sheer sep Tre of
combat that is clever and diabolical
actually that's what I encourage here at
real reject yes fall in love with
somebody at the age of 18 I was made an
officer given a
command I just want to know what frame
rates they are going in between it's a
very specific camera that they that they
use it's like 10 frames a second 600
frames a
second ooh I can't tell which is cooler
reloading the gun or shooting the gun
and screaming it's actually kind of cool
to see a laser gun that requires a
Reload
yeah did she lead them to
Conquest how many towns and Villages did
you destroy with your own two hands
h Bounty Hunter
whoa
whoa that that is invive yeah that's our
guy that's the man we came to see the
one that introduced me to the blood axis
well it's time to have a fight scene in
the rain let's go let's get it
going this honestly feels more like what
Booka Boba Fett wanted I dude seriously
got to give it to
this our best chance to find the blood
axis is to contact the the beans it
might expose us first we find General
Titus then we'll see about your Rebels
Titus and
ramadon first time son move on he's not
for sale everything's for sale in this
place
so upstairs with relatively clean sh
very generous this is Progressive but I
don't think so oh wow I said move on
[__] this guy feels like a 300
character has anyone here heard of
General Titus turn his own men on the
mother world's forces
the damn last I heard he was fighting in
the Coliseum at poock Pollock Troy guess
we need to find a ship to take us to
Pollock you're were catching
on you're naming the plot beats you
should have killed me I'm going to give
you one chance are you going to give all
of us one
chance we all have a
gun
killer
I love the
bartender oh sideways
sexyon
[Music]
shootout
whoa he's chosen a side
boom yeah I don't like Bounty Hunters
and to be clear I don't like Bounty
Hunters either so you a gun for hire no
that's not my thing then what are you Mr
wild card I heard you in there trying to
get to poock I could help you oh I
understand we're just simple fous we're
searching for soldiers for a fight
against the you're full as [__] man my
name's Kai come on my ship's DED at
Port nice to meet you Kai Kai like him
already
all right so far I think everything is
obvious as the statement as it is for a
Zack Snider film technically gorgeous a
nice little hodge podge of a whole bunch
of other things aesthetically yeah Grand
cool action great visuals good
atmosphere mood still not super invested
in the
characters he is like the last bit of
oomph it needs is like truly distinct
and interesting characters yeah I'm
liking the movie don't get me wrong I am
I'm really liking it but I I could use
some investment in the characters a
little stronger that is not just explain
your background to me it does make you
wonder like is the is the director's cut
just going to be like a bunch of little
character moments add it back
in what is the man doing he's inflating
his muscles theyve captured a creature
that has important information about the
Insurgent Deborah BL and her brother
wowe that's C let me get it on with my
hentti creature here these people want
to talk to you we got that chain on your
leg you're here to accuse me of crimes
against the mother world I'm going to
his charged take it up with him it's not
why we're here would you like to do more
crimes against the mother world and
we're looking to hire some fighters to
train and protect us against a force
from the mother world like the seven
samur 300,000 darham ought to cover any
inconvenience I've suffered we don't
have that kind of money no money what do
you have I do love to gamble if ter can
break that creature out there his deaths
are squared with me it's like he knew
what it was before it was even said
[Music]
yep
wow oh he bound show
respect
is this the language this mythical bird
speaks Yep they're from the same place
just the two of
them tame the
horse let's move it along really quick I
was
to this sequence any longer in the
director's cut just say sh to the bar
how do I get out of this dead y High St
got Tam that Beast he tames the Beast
the Beast immediately
yeah oh look sexy oh
yeah dud Jake Sully you did it he is
impressive
wow a lot of these locations do look
very real
yeah
ow is he trying to Buck him
off
oh
ouch come out he is a very physically
fit man let's go t
Hawk wonder what Zack Snider's Clash of
the Titans would be like with your
reputation we thought it might be
something you'd be interested in Nemesis
please please hold her H nemesis this I
just want to talk I'm clearly distressed
that's true oh wow what the hell what is
she holding on to I know why you're here
you want the child you're that lady from
Doctor Who yes I do you can't have this
one this one is mine child of spider she
has a mother who's waiting who's missing
them and why should I care about that
Mother's pain when no one is here for my
pain oh it's um gal alone before they
came taste the air weakens my eggs and
now my children cannot emerge she looks
like the Bor Queen it's just I will kill
this child and I will keep killing until
every mother weeps tears of regret
forever having come to the minds of dag
the minds of
dagas we're just going to kill this kill
this creature off I guess she's got
to he's get an insert of Charlie hun him
wow I like all of her different
eyeballs I guess having that many legs
is both an advantage and a
vulnerability
nice whoa damn how did they film this
damn I don't know by removing the head
or destroy the
bread Dam ah that should do
it oh oh
sexy let's
go damn shotgun blade lightsabers it's a
nice way to keep it just this side of
not lightsaber but still light saer yeah
they're technically metal they're just
super
hot oh oh yeah I like the waves that
preced it cauterize that
wound wow the the necessity for a
director's cut has never felt more
necessary to me until we got to this
part of the movie literally not like I
feel like we just skipped a whole like
important chunk here to really get
invested in this one the entire team's
intro is just their action scene yeah
but this like whole other side of the
world now and it's behaving like I
already know the vibe of this character
more than from just these few moments
for my loyalty and service I was
promoted to the elite guard of the royal
family the appointment was engineered by
my father ohoh the owls of
Gul I couldn't have known him was
something I was given the honor of being
The Bodyguard to princess Issa oh my God
damn what did you do in the old stories
of the queen it was said that she had
the power to give life
ah she's
Jesus she's Jesus damn and he was
believe that the princess might have
that same power I saw on more than one
occasion things that I couldn't explain
I half expected it to be like grotesque
I'm a bird back to
life chir
chirp a lady you know exactly what you
just witnessed you saw a dead birg
brought to her and was resurrected
Lazarus come on man pretty
straightforward actually when she
becomes Queen I believe she'll bring her
compassion that I've lost after all
these hard years of war very believable
beard of course and all of his
Expressions not to make it fall
off Coliseum nice straight up called
Gladiator I didn't even notice that s
yep
romane they go the
[Music]
house oh my dude let's go back in
Gladiator again that's jimon hansu
pretty sure are you not General Titus I
don't know you running mouth about
because my best hope is that long ago
General is still in front of me oh he is
I'm here to make you an offer to give
you a chance at Redemption I am beyond
Redemption what about all the dead men
you once commanded gotta grow your
Shazam beard out if not Redemption what
about
Revenge Revenge chin recruited character
cut to reactions of the people watching
recruited
character is that it they just recruit
him yep he's in okay all right we're on
the way all right next one check
okay the N flaws are really begin
like like about 20 five minutes ago they
really started showing themselves the
more they cut the more they go the
quicker they the more they cut to all of
them watching her recruit the more I'm
like oh wait there's a team here and I
don't feel like it at
all look at that
Eclipse I'd love to see a map of this
galaxy
it's a very interestingly designed
Planet
oh Ray
Fisher that's Ray Fisher I believe it is
we bought your grain to feed our
Fighters do not confuse your business of
Commerce with our business of Revolution
oo but we are no longer in need of your
grain King Leviticus kindness has been
more than enough to sustain us uhoh
we're going to get into a big blowout we
eat kindness now
with you we can mount a real defense we
can pay you with the Surplus from our
Harvest that ship cannot be destroyed by
a few dozen Fighters this man is not a
revolutionary he's a simple farmer o
their Village is now threatened by
Admiral Noble in pursuit of your
Revolution who are
you I will
go sure my man we cannot fight in the
open against the king's cage if the
farmer found us it won't be long before
Noble does and I will not allow another
world to fall in our name I really need
to start caring about some people I'm
not going to lie he was in the Snider
cut I love him he come seeking our help
to stand against a dread knot of the
mother world is that not what we stand
for we haven't gotten a strong sense yet
of the Paul that the that the mother
World World cast over everyone yeah and
we're like so late into the
yeah who among you is willing to Die For
What We Believe rather than hide behind
it I mean I guess we're just left to
assume that every slum and shitty place
we've seen so far is that way because of
the mother world but be nice to see some
regular people under the foot of tyranny
whever we wherever we cut to like some
type of wrong and Justice that's been
done to the people of the mother
world because of how the mother World
affected them in some way like there
needs to be something personal and
there's nothing really personal yet
other than but they'll give like back
story like General backstory or
generalization of them so the rise of a
rebellion is not really felt as a
catharsis due to that and we're an hour
and a half in so I feel like I can say
that confidently nah wait another 30
minutes patient why would he agree to
help you you think they shouldn't seems
shortsighted this whole thing feels
short guilt it's a powerful thing I
guilt the underbelly of honor o you had
more resist and power to speak of you
wouldn't need you so badly you willing
to fight with us since you're begging I
finally decided after several stops
there's one complication sh in the cargo
hold I could bu way and godal might be
wise to Seer my ties to Life as a thief
before we go picking a fight with the
dreadnut and we can pick up another
teammate along the
way what no
no I've told you the truth I have
nothing more I swear to God man this
movie doesn't nominate for visuals like
it is it is remarkable like like the
visuals are remarkable oh yeah it is the
best visual effects movie Heavy movie
I've seen all
year that ship is named The King's gate
no so we named the ship to remind us of
the power in that benevolent gaze was
lost to charity M that if by God's will
that gaze should fall upon us and be
held for even the briefest of moments
charity help get the Snider cut going
yep a slow it down nope ouch now we
looks like a femur or
something we received a message from one
of her HW Shaws they're closing in on
the blood AIS they supposed to be like
the B Jester what are these guys yeah I
guess so but once you've raised the
Planet will revu extract the exact
location of the rest of the
insurgents and Destroy them once and for
all yes I don't even think they care
about the farmers anymore yeah seems
like such a small fish on their docket
are we
looking everything's done what all right
let's move what yeah on your Mark it's
an it's a
trap no
How Could
You
oo no oh no
no
a good reveal they're like the battle
droids but or the the ones that roll up
and but if they could imprison you
instead of shoot you on your
KNE what the hell Charlie
hunam now is not the time to be a hero
talking to the wrong character about
that yeah Gunner's nothing but or should
I call you arthus he knows why did you
say that do you know what the mother
world did to my planet can we see it
they tortured every man woman and child
is he from snow world oh maybe you know
what that taught me look out for
yourself never set foot on the wrong
side of History wow is that what you
think we're doing no you've chosen a
side that doesn't even make it to the
history books what happened to honor
what did happen to it piece of
[__] there good scene be more
heartbreaking if I cared about them what
are you talking
about Commander blood X leader of the
very Insurgency the king Gaz was sent to
this back quarter of the Galaxy to
capture yeah edre is great at this
though yeah is really it's my favorite
part I understand why all of them are
here but you what could you possibly
hope to gain by mounting such a feeble
stand the legendary swordswoman known
only by the name of Nemesis a you know
what you've done for me AR assembling
yourself as
such you've promoted me to the top I'll
be a hero of the realm the write songs
of my Feats of Courage it's not like I
didn't do all the work have him killed
you play your cards right you at least
might make it out of this life you're
sick and you're a coward which is
worse all you have to do is pull the
trigger more of a squeeze really is it a
ploy that actually helps yeah is he
about to do a double double agent turn
it's going to turn into a
[Music]
gun oh yeah let's
go
them did they all get free I don't think
so I'm surprised the others haven't been
swis cheesed by
now yes the way they realize these
blades is incredible
yeah it is like a femur or a big bone
that's
cool whoa great camera m shot on the
guns I got cool extras in this
fight
look at the ABS whoa what she doing
there she just using them as like a
shield
awesome oh no
oh no is that the end of Ray Fisher's
character I hope
not
no no
uhoh hot stuff right there yeah I want
to know what her workout regimen was for
[Music]
this
oh
whoa beautiful
devastation
oh you broke his bone no
Fu come on Sophia Bella what' you eat
all those egg whites for
yeah ah
yeah hey
she is
strong oh whip his ass yeah give him the
beat
[Music]
down oh nice she didn't break it before
I like this style of how she has to
slowly chip down and away at his weapon
yeah
ah no
damn stabbed in the leg with a leg
bone
oh nice this is
perfect
wow not
bad lost my pearlies in the war this is
more than just a foreign PR officer and
some of his men is it it's the beginning
of something something that's for sure
they have to tell us what happened after
the death of a Nal protocol would demand
the ship's return that's good we still
get paid I presume a deal is a deal paid
an honor you thanks gar you know I never
did trust that
Pilot We all owe him thanks I have time
enough to trust the
pilot wow gar Redemption is this the end
of the movie no is what that dead Bounty
Hunter said true that you're a is Kai
was a liar and a thief when nearly
Soldier all for a profit but yes it's is
also my name
there that's our village this looks like
the wheat field from 300 before they
leave for battle let's
go where's our robot oh it's our robot
hey whoa what just happened he's going
to go become Merlin and live in the
woods that dude had a lot of a stream
development
yep whole life story y flower crown grew
into
antlers roughing it in the land do ad
screen
live wasted no
time nice spray Zack Snyder is the one
guy for whom like no matter what the
quality of the movie is you want the art
of book oh yeah
absolutely why is this this guy is so
important wow oh yeah when he was like
filling himself up and stuff yeah when
he was smoking that
hookah link is
established love how you can get away
with gor like that when it's like oh
he's an Android yeah it's sci-fi it's
not real baby
Neo is he going to mutate asterid energy
send
him send him are there more bodies is he
on
vormir getting put into a meeting look
like a leviathan underneath the water
what the hell Master bisari Oscar Isaac
I have found arus she was in the company
of the disgraced General Titus and
Darian bladex we are close to capturing
them did you think that this would be
good news look how real that old Agee
makeup the beard oh that too so she is
within our grasp keep reiterating who
these people
are you will capture my daughter alive
and bring back my precious child to me
the villains have way more presence than
any of the protagonists yeah
absolutely bring him back just to kill
him
again
wow I hope we see full frontal in the
director's cut I have no heart me to
brain function hit him with everything
it's not only it's like Doctor Who
Aesthetics fire
everything
yeah
nice
a
all
right interesting all right three people
wrote that
screenplay
well I got
thoughts I've got thoughts do you
know and I will tell you this
much on that these thoughts wouldn't be
possible oh what's that without today's
sponsors thank you to Shopify for
sponsoring which is what we use for our
merch store and is our gamechanging
partner in e-commerce so whether you're
launching a passion project or scaling
to new heights Shopify is e-commerce
Powerhouse guing you at every step from
creating your first online store to
opening physical locations Shopify makes
it seamless it's perfect whether you're
selling exclusive merch or unique
Collectibles thanks to their
all-encompassing platform for both
online and inore sales their checkout
system unmatched it's 36% more effective
at converting visitors into buyers than
other platforms and let's not forget
Shopify magic the AI TOA elevates your
business with minimal effort but
seriously reflecting on our journey
using Shopify for www. reation shop.com
it's been transformative the transition
smooth growth exponential thank you
again reject Nation from simplifying
sales to scaling our offerings Shopify
has been a Cornerstone of our success
and Shopify isn't just for us owers 10%
of us e-commerce backing businesses big
and small and over 175 countries there
are war-winning support always there to
guide you so ready to join the
revolution sign up for Shopify it only a
dollar a month at shopify.com rejects
all overc case shopify.com reex start
your Shopify success story now let's
grow together with Shopify team big
thanks to expressvpn for sponsoring this
video a real game changer I've been
using for years that's right years so
whenever they want to work with us it's
an instant yes you've likely heard about
expressvpn for online privacy and
security but there's more to it than
that however there was a very real
incident recently with Spectrum Shing
down my internet and contacting me due
to a suspecting hacking attempt and
funny enough I realized I hadn't
actually activated my expressvpn on my
new laptop that I got a couple of months
ago so I was paying the consequences
having faced a serious hacking issue on
YouTube a couple years ago that made
expressvpn my go-to for both security
and freedom I mean it and yes what
you've heard is true believe me this
channel knows you can use expressvpn to
watch movies and shows on Netflix that
are not available in your country this
means accessing a vast rate of content
of over a 100 countries like a global
Cinema your fingertips it's super easy
open expressvpn switch locations refresh
the brow and there you have it whether
it's kramas on South Korean Netflix Hulu
BBC I player YouTube or more expressvpn
has you covered and it's incredibly fast
ensuring no buffering or lack for smooth
HD streaming it's versatile too working
on not just computers but phones media
consoles Smart TVs and more this means
you can enjoy your favorite shows on
anywhere any screen protect and elevate
your internet experience so if you want
to get access to hundreds of new shows
use my link expressvpn.com Rejects and
you can get an extra 3 months of
expressvpn for free that's Express
vpn.com rejects so head to
expressvpn.com rejects to learn more
thank you again all righty thank you to
our sponsors and let's talk about the
rebel Moon a song bird of Fire and Ice
uh what's it called child a child of
fire okay yeah that's easy enough to
remember I shouldn't have such a hard
time any who um yeah overall I liked it
I thought I might have like a lot of
thoughts on this movie movie and my
thoughts I feel like are very simple and
straightforward I express them
throughout the reaction if you guys are
listening to this on Apple and Spotify
you can go ahead rate this review um and
yeah that would be very much appreciated
any who yeah so obviously he goes out
saying it's a Zack snd film you expect
it to look good rare is the day I can't
even think of a day where we were here
and said this film looks awful I don't
think we've ever said that and I think
this is one of his
best looking films he has ever done it
is stunning from beginning to end I the
only liveaction film I haven't seen of
his is um Sucker Punch and from what I
understand of that movie is it supposed
to kind of feel a little bit like a
dream I don't know anything about the
movie really so I it's supposed to feel
like a dream and what I was loving about
the Aesthetics here is that while it is
like a dream come true of watching like
a child's fantasy come to life it it
still felt tangible and real and that's
the element of it that has it feeling
lived in is just how gorgeous not like
the blend of practical effects the
everything that's going on in the
background the backdrops of things not
just what's in the center of frame but
the backdrops uh the
skies all of it was stunning this is
probably in terms of visual effects it
you know like we had some great looking
movies this year and but in terms of
movie that heavily relies on CGI I would
say this is undoubtedly the best looking
movie I've seen all year that does that
I can't think of another one can you I
can't think of another one when way
Wilder was like the way end of last year
right yeah it does not count that count
as last year the best uh looking one of
the I mean yeah like all the effects
from the creatures to the ships to the
you know Ming of all the movie Magic
looked beautiful absolutely absolutely
the action again
one thing you expect from Zack sneer the
action is going to be cool the action
was really cool and I think his Mastery
blend of he's known for his slow-mo and
I actually feel like there wasn't as
much slow-mo as I thought there would be
yeah it's funny because you look at this
and you hear like oh it's been cut down
so like oh what are they going to do
just indulge in tons and tons of SLA but
really it was only a couple you know
punctuation shots that hearken to that
like 300 style speed ramping yeah and uh
and I mean too just to real quick to
bolster the effects I do admire that you
know for as much as Zack Snyder came to
Big prominence with a movie like 300
that is like all shot on green screens
you know like you do appreciate that
while there are tons and tons of visual
effects they built the town apparently
and they you know built these fields and
stuff like that and and those things go
a long way towards selling a lot of this
stuff too I would say definitely because
it it all looked real and a lot of times
I couldn't tell like what was real and
what wasn't in terms of certain
backdrops that they were happing and
like the costumes like everything from a
practical standpoint the music again who
who did is it Tom
Yen I don't know nit I don't know he's
not it's not Han Zimmer but it sounds
close one of Han Zimmer junky Exel or
Tom Hulen smoken Borger we had IMDb
right I know but it's easier just to ask
Google Tom Hulen Tom Hulen Borg he did
do the score for it then again the
percussive tune with the mixture of
stuff that felt very
tribalistic um as well as like
orchestral sounds like so much of the
mood and Aura relied heavily on its
aesthetic and one thing that you can say
that speaks loudly to Zack Snider's
films is aesthetically speaking that in
itself is one of the voices of the movie
you know it's like you can look at
script which has like dialogue and
performances and all those things and
that is just one element of the voice
and often times that is the main
Reliance of voice and is really
important part but I think with Zack snd
you want to see how much of that really
lands and I do think that you know even
if at times where there were like
complaints happening or things about
characterization or narrative it
was you I I would find myself like
complaining about something and then
being like but they're going damn look
at this you know like it's imminently
watchable yeah and a lot of the time
what I find that happens with me in a
movie and I've even had this with other
Zack Snider films uh to some of his the
iCal Cuts I would say is I will be
watching it and I won't I might have
issues with the story and then this but
for a lot of films out there I will find
that yeah it looks pretty but man I'm
just so bored I'm just so checked out
because of the narrative itself is so
not doing it for me and that it won't
that it won't matter and then I I would
find myself here being like no I still
like love what I'm looking at like I
still really love what I'm looking at
I'm not on any substances right now or
anything I'm totally sober Greg and I
would find myself still going whoa I am
engrossed by this and especially to
watch this with headphones on uh I think
uh being absorbed into the sound design
so so much of this was working for me on
just the technical aspect and not
everything narratively is bad or
something like that right uh it but on
the technical aspect of of it all I was
so engrossed by the painting I was
witnessing that that alone is enough for
me to recommend it it is just off of
that and it's not the usual types like
there's some Zack Snider ear marks you
would normally
expect however I still think it goes it
elevates above that you know like lately
he's been kind of doing something that's
more realworld the blend Army of
Darkness uh I would even say even Z dead
army army of the Dead uh Zack Snider's
Justice League a Batman v Superman stuff
that feels more real world inhabited
yeah it's been a while since he's done a
movie that's just purely a Fantastical
realm yeah you know and that's what
that's what makes me curious to see
Sucker Punch and and this seems like a
complement to the vague things I know
about that except in like a much less
off-putting package yeah you know um and
you know then then we comes to
performances I would say the highlights
for me are Ed screen MH uh I thought he
was like he was a scene stealer whenever
he was there yeah he's just got so much
I don't know he's having fun chewing the
scenery but not doing it too much he's a
villain in Deadpool he yeah yeah see he
was kind of like whatever there and so
see him play another villain here and
obviously riffing on Nazis I still he's
gotten better each time when he's done
CU he was a villain in aita of battle
Angel and that's right and he's usually
like boring he's like he's like he's
like some he's like a Jai Courtney to me
yeah know he totally is and he like took
over the transporter for a hot second
and that didn't last long yeah where he
can be that guy where he can be oh I
don't remember now I finally remember
him game I did not I I remember that
there was a switcher that happened I
could not pull the face now I see it
like he was the first one right yeah he
was Dario narz and then the guy who
plays Gunner he was the second one and
he was the main one who was around
that's right yes yes and he was with
ailia Clark I forget which I forgot
which character it was yeah um yeah yeah
yeah okay I well anyway I thought he was
excellent here um the performers overall
were good I would say but I really don't
know see the difference with
um no I want to say I don't know like I
think they're all good uh and I have
some specific ones I want to kind of
Target a little bit here put a Target on
them Target on your back I guess I don't
really know how strong the characters
are because of this director's cut
theatrical cut deogo that we're in just
just so obviously gutted of character
beats yeah like Batman v Superman was
the start of like he's done other
director's Cuts before but bat Superman
was to me the bigger the biggest
Testament and the most vocal one of you
watch an extended version and it's
actually so much better and that was
only like 15 to 20 minutes longer yeah
but it was and the performances were
even stronger and and all these things
and the chemistry was there and and the
difference with that was I could
actually see a version where that would
exist yeah from watching the theatrical
version yeah because you still had like
galado made an impression I Ben Affleck
people were like he's great in this you
know and even for people like us who
didn't like that theatrical Cub when we
saw it we were like but they're really
good and like they stand out and when
they're on screen they're awesome Alfred
like there were these performers that
were there that you just knew were
excellent and then of course having like
being acquainted with Henry caval and
Mana steel prior so there was a lot
working for it we're here this is an
introduction to a bunch of new
characters um you know there a there's a
new IP that's being created and so this
is my are introduction allot of them and
and honestly like my the biggest letdown
for the movie for me
is the introductions of them I could see
one
person not one person why am I saying
like that uh I could see one version is
the word looking for you have no idea
how long the DAT okay you're doing great
you're doing I didn't want it to I don't
want that to bleed over I want want to
end this strong so you could see I could
see one version of this where you could
see sort of the um it's it's how I felt
when we were first getting to know Kora
Sophia Bella's character like sure is
this so expositional is this so on the
Node is this so familiar is this so like
self poetic pretentious Romanticism with
its own dialogue yeah but it felt
intentional it felt purposeful so I was
like I don't know I'm digging it I mean
is this what people were complaining
about because I if that's what it is I
don't give a [__] like I like it it was
when we started getting to other
characters as the recruitment process
started happening where I'm like okay we
spend a good chunk of time here with
Village PE farmer people like the first
40 minutes is just with them and then
everyone else is like a quick five to
seven minutes other than guy who gets
bird uh everything else is like a quick
five to 7 minutes would just like get
some backstory that RI on like uh
oh my God John help me with the word
colonialization colonization
colonization with colonization and can
feel a little bit poetic but honestly it
feels hacked up in my in my viewing
experience it felt hacked up there were
times where we would like cut to a
character like lady with swords uh where
I was like wait a minute I feel like
there's something here that's completely
missing of how we got here that I have
no investment in what's happening here
and that investment would just
constantly get more diluted the more we
would meet a new character like by the
time we got to Ray Fisher's character I
was like who's this okay there's
supposed to be this big Rising catharsis
and rebellion and then he dies and I'm
like I don't really I don't really care
cuz I don't really know this guy like at
all I only kind of care cuz I know it's
Ray
fer this was a fascinating experience
because to me this movie felt like what
happens to a movie when it becomes a
reaction highlight real like it's it's
it feels like it is reduced down to like
here's the main beats you need to
understand and to support whatever we're
about to say but you know without the
reaction part actually happening it's
just the movie yeah it felt like
somebody yeah ran all these cliets
together and I wonder what it would be
like to watch this without the knowledge
that there's going to be a director's
cut and all that stuff and whoever's
idea it was and why yeah it's
interesting because at the beginning
with the stuff with Sophia Bella and
meeting you know this world ofelt you
are like okay maybe the the directness
and the familiarity of this is like a
choice right could be and I'm fine with
that because yeah sometimes things
aren't trying to reinvent the wheel
they're just trying to put a
particularly nice shine and spin on it
right but uh yeah once you get to a
certain point it feels like all you get
is the punch for everybody's intro and
none of the lead up to any of that and
it really suffers dynamically because of
that and the visuals are working
overtime to sell you everything and it's
fascinating because this
is like I enjoyed watching it and and I
wanted to keep watching it and I think
Zack Snyder is always like a really uh I
don't know skilled and enthusiastic
World Builder esthetician you know like
I always get the sense that there is
like a rich Bedrock of stuff even if
it's comprised of many parts like I'm
always interested in what his Visions
are and in spending time in these worlds
again not having seen Sucker Punch I've
heard some people say that movie is kind
of off-putting but the rest of them
usually I'm like even if the plotting
isn't working for me I'm still like
engrossed in the place of this and so
yeah seeing like bad reviews going in I
don't feel quite that way but at the
same time I kind of agree with all the
gripes it's like weird I I'm not mad or
and I'm not almost even like let down
but it is just so apparent that there's
so much missing that makes this a really
story deficient experience so it does
ironically feel the most like a movie
made to sell TVs out of any of his
movies uh thus far because it starts to
feel like somebody who like makes
commercials directed it which I mean you
know he he did make commercials but uh
you know I don't know it's a I'm trying
to put my finger on like how to describe
my feeling on this movie I would say the
visuals are what push it over to like a
6.5 to 7 for me 6.5 being totally honest
it's like a 6.5 five maybe a six it's
like if I was a Rotten Tomato score I
would just barely be passing fresh
because the narrative and characters
themselves just don't cut it for me here
like there's so many of them and they're
all kind of given essentially the same
kind of story and dialogue and
background with a slightly different
tinge of something he's a general but
it's all the same been disgraced oh you
were a mother and you lost your kid and
you've got a vendetta for that and yeah
yeah and and I think um like Sophia
Bella's
Kora I think physically she's a a like
very capable and an imposing figure down
like she's great physic like I totally
buy and believe her like that her body
language it's really again maybe in the
extended version with the expansion on
dialogue scene she's given it works but
here I don't know it just wasn't strong
enough of a performer to uh be
captivating in those moments where she
was having like big dialogue moments
because the scenes themselves aren't
strong enough because there's everything
surrounding or leading up and yada yada
yada you know you know what a lot of
this felt like to me what it it it felt
like and I know this isn't the case
because there's like a 4-Hour version
out there it it felt like someone typed
into Chat
gbt N I want to do a movie that takes
place that's a combination of Star Wars
Dune Lord of the Rings and uh write me a
movie that and the Magnificent Seven
Seven Samurai write me a movie that is
that and that is what this is and I
don't take offense to that or find it um
egregious in any way because Zack
Snider's voice and uh what he's
gravitated towards if you look at his
phography I haven't seen Sucker Punch of
Legends of go whatever um is you know
like the things he's known for are
adaptations and as and then when he does
something that's original it this whole
point is being derivative and and
homaging like a billion other things
like is like being a kid crashing all
your favorite stuff together yeah yeah
like so when it comes when you really
think about it storywise when it comes
to originality that's not really what
people are drawn to Zack Snyder about in
terms of story I'm talking about it's
the feeling and the vibe and the and the
awe of the spectacle that he is able to
communicate yeah cuz narratively
story-wise none of this really
Everything feels like it's from
something else I've seen this feels like
like my bad memory of a movie except it
was the whole movie well yeah I mean not
bad in terms of like a sour memory but
like I don't remember all of this movie
and that feels like all of the what they
gave us here and that's how I feel when
watching this is like I uh I don't I
don't mind that that it's derivative of
like a billion other things I don't mind
that I I really don't um cuz you could
feel a an eager inspiration of being
like oh this is kind of like my this
like you said during the reaction like
this is how zacker will often take the
Fantastical thing we all know when he's
doing like one of his derivative pieces
and then like what's the harsher reality
version of this and that's what he does
that's that's just what we we know him
to do and and so when watching this I'm
like yeah it's about what I'd expect uh
when watching the trailer for this movie
uh story-wise but one thing I cannot
forgive a movie on is if you're going to
have this many characters they got to
have chemistry mhm and the characters
have to be got make a team especially
that's what I mean it's an ensemble of a
team that's Banning together for a cause
I'm like well you got to get your Simple
Story down really easy to latch on to um
because the most you got to do is like
at least make up for lack of story with
good with um I don't know fun to watch
characters they're not even like f
that's the problem is the characters
aren't even like fun to watch well they
didn't give them any time to build
comaraderie or build any kind of team
spirit of any kind like like uh Sophia
Bella's character has like a
conversation with the Charlie hunam
character and that's only really to
convince us he's not a bad guy right
before the twist comes around that he is
a bad guy and so like it seems pretty
likely that like all of the stuff that's
missing from this is probably all the
stuff is going to go back into the
director's cut but it is funny to me
whoever made it this way from you know
the powers that be because it does
betray the tone and that Cornerstone of
Zack Snider's aesthetic in making these
things feel more real because by
removing us from any time spent with the
characters and removing us from time
spent in the world past that opening bit
in velt where you spend the most
breathable room getting to know the
place like you're traveling to so many
distant interesting looking worlds and
you can feel the love from behind the
camera for what all these creatures and
places and and all these political
minations are but it undercuts that grit
of realism by not having any meat on
that bone and you brought up multiple
times during the movie it's like they
let us know via dialogue how terrible
the mother world is um and you know Ed
screen good villain the guy who is her
like surrogate father who picks her up
on the battlefield actually some decent
presents from that guy like interesting
formidable presents however yeah you
don't really feel you don't get to
witness the true horrific might of the
mother world you just kind of I don't
know everywhere you go is kind of crappy
so you just have to assume that that's
their fault or something yeah like if
you look at the movies as borrowing from
yeah see I think the strongest part of
this movie is the before they venture
out on the quest yeah cuz it is just
like a pretty fine Blockbuster yeah the
for the first 45 minutes like when when
she actually like as cliche as it is
with like girl about to be assaulted and
then main character usually it's a guy
who's like the main character to step in
and save the day um so as as clich as
much a Trope as it is um I still really
like like this is effective this is
strong I'm rooting for Sophia Bella I
want to get to know who she is that and
and and the farmer village town like I
kind of feel like we lost sight of all
that and when they started going out and
exploring the Galaxy is when the movie
slowly just kept starting smaller and
smaller in terms of impact in terms of
emotional impact and interest you know
it's like we just kept going to other
parts of the world and the story itself
the Grossman of that just started to
dwindle when I was like I was actually
extremely more invested in this we were
just in this one section this one spot
yeah and and uh and I think what they do
with Sophia Bella's character that I I
find is not really it seems like the
script confus and maybe this is just the
theatrical version it feels like the
script
confuses bombastic flashbacks with heavy
amounts of exposition for World building
and character development yes it when
that's not what's really they're just
kind of explaining [__] you know and
yeah they're just giving setups so that
you know what the motivations are so
that we know why we're fighting blah
blah blah yeah and yeah to that point
about the motherland like for
comparisons and compared to the things
that it's derived from like even in the
first Star Wars movie you're not
watching the Empire like you know
destroy Villages left and right or some
[__] like they some but when you go to
towns there's like Stormtroopers there
and there's a lot of emphasis and talk
about it you see them destroy all yeah
yeah you see could pop off at any moment
and there's a lot of and there's not as
many cutting around to so you're really
focused and a lot of the conversations
are about like here's what the Empire
will do like everywhere you go the the
vibe of the Empire is around in some
capacity Doom same thing you know um and
you get a sense for the proximity of
places in those worlds yeah yeah exactly
and I like the idea idea of doing like a
Seven Samurai but on a galactic level um
but the problem is Seven Samurai and
magnificent 7 those movies are all about
one town and and like this one dude
who's this one this group of people who
are oppressing this one town you know
and it's very it's it's yeah that's why
that first hour is effective for that
yeah those movies are sprawling and they
are long but but they are sort of simple
in that way as you get the team together
they got to fortify the villagers help
them fight for themselves and then they
take on the bad guy yeah so when you
start cutting around and you're trying
to do like additional World building on
top of world bid and they start to like
kind of lose sight of it so to me I was
like there's a lot of potential that
kind of just seems like it's getting
lost in the in the array of things now
it's getting so caught up in uh
delivering information and wanting to be
cool that we are now missing out on just
like the basics and the basics being an
ensemble movie where you got like great
like you have so many great actors here
but you know the writing is so weak to
of them to the point where they're not
even enough to elevate it to make the
characters actually interesting they
don't even get a chance to shine through
that yeah it's like it really feels like
you you got whisked past something
really fast like somebody pulled you
into a room and said look at all this
cool stuff but we got to run through
here we got to get out of here cuz we
got another one of these to get to right
yeah and uh like it really does feel
like a like a like a recollection in
hindsight but made into a movie somehow
and and it's like you have these
creatures and things you have like I I
really enjoyed that spider scene with
Jenna Malone uh and that you know there
were so many alien species and stuff
like that and those are things that give
you questions that you as a viewer will
probably happily give the movie A little
extra time and benefit of the doubt to
go exploring and I do think it's funny
that Zack Snider seems like a filmmaker
who just I don't know if it's a good
thing or not but I he just seems like he
has to make a long mov there's no other
way he has to make a long ass movie and
this is like two hours and it feels like
yeah like it's been shredded down to
this felt kind of like a less maddening
to me version of what happened to Batman
v Superman and I get the sense more was
cut from this where it's like let's just
trim out as much as we can to get to two
hours and whatever that is we're going
to put it out and I felt like the
shredding wasn't really felt until they
start until they left Farmland yeah the
part where it's it weirdly I liked that
we got to establish velt and and the
people there and and we got to spend
some time in that however funny enough I
would trade it for the rushed prologue
intro thing if it meant we could breathe
in assembling the team cuz that's what's
really important like you you got to
care for the home that you're fighting
for and for her to come back and be like
oh yeah she says something about you
know like calling it home being a nice
thing uh but in a movie like this where
the whole charm is going to be the team
and their Dynamic together and each of
them having unique moments when the
fight finally you know reaches ahead and
you know know some people aren't going
to make it I I would have happily traded
20 or more of those opening minutes on
velt for Flesh on those bones because it
does start to feel like some kind of
greatest hits medley from comprised of a
bunch of complete albums you've never
heard yeah like uh especially if you
want to get people to watch like part
two you know and I know there's a lot of
people I'm seing I'm sure if I go on
Twitter there's a lot of people who are
like loving this this right now critics
score bad audience score middling um and
I to me though
it yeah like I kind
of it's not either put more work in your
theatrical cut or or don't rely on
people having to watch your director's
cut I I don't I don't agree with how the
handling of that it's streaming you
they're there aren't as many rules and
like if anyone is going to if you have
any chance of getting big numbers on a
long long movie it's a Zack Snider joint
and feels like a disservice to
everything going on here and to the
sequel to split this in half and then do
a mono cut because from my understanding
the director's cut will be both Parts
Plus an hour so like at that point just
do that or find a way to cut that
version in half because this seems I
don't know like I I I would be
fascinated in the future when more you
know when you can I'm sure they're ndas
and whatever I would I would be curious
to hear the story of this later down the
line because if I was Zack Snyder making
a movie I'm not sure I would be totally
thrilled with this cut and he's like oh
yeah the director's cut feels like a
whole different movie and while I don't
think that that's necessarily 100% true
I'm like I could see how it definitely
would feel like a different experience
because this is It's just so strange I
can't even put my I can't find a proper
word cuz I wouldn't call this bad
but it is clearly deficient of things
that are like super necessary like there
are so many elements that do it doesn't
have to be black and white I I think
like everything that's good about it is
obvious and the things that are bad
about it are also obvious yeah it's like
part of me is like I liked it it's sub
subjectively speaking of course I'm sure
there are people who really like some of
these characters I don't I'm not going
to we won't try to take that away from
you yeah and I mean sure there there's
plenty that like an actor you like and
you know a cool look can do and I I you
know I certainly you know gravitate
towards those things too and this is I
don't know this is one of those things
where I'm happy to want to learn more
about these characters rather than
finishing this and being like I don't
care to see any more of this stuff like
you know there there's only more
Goodwill that can be built on top of
this because yeah at the end of the day
and I've heard some people mention the
Creator uh while talking about this
movie and that is another movie that is
like supremely derivative of a bunch of
things but has a good amount more and it
doesn't even fully breathe as well as it
could do but that movie you know in
being quite familiar still manages to
feel like kind of a rich experience or
one of those you walk out of and you're
like you know that's not perfect but a
real big Applause for the effort and
here I'm like this isn't perfect
Applause for the effort but also I feel
like you could have easily not been in
this position yeah you know a hundred
different ways I don't know but that's
just STP on it I'm like somewhere
between a 6 to a
6.5 keep keeps going down for me a
little bit I'm excited for part two I'm
definitely like there's enough in here
to push you right past that rotten line
like visually but in terms of I'm just
looking at like narrative and story you
know like I could watch a movie that's
riddle with cliches sure I could watch a
movie that's riddle that's so derivative
but it's like it's also about like what
is the emotion it's leaving me with and
and uh to me it it like the emotion it
left me with was like there's a lot I
admired here in my head and emotionally
I was like H it's kind
of emotionally it's a little vacant on
the emotion side that's a good word for
it yeah doesn't even feel like there's a
chance to
connect there's nothing there's nothing
like nothing really brought like a big
smile to my face nothing like shocked me
and even like the while the action's
like really cool to look at it's not
memorable enough for me to be like I'll
at least want to turn in for Part Two
for the Crazy Action yeah you know it's
like even with Transformers you'd be
like well I [__] action though you
know or some [__] actually that's a bad
I hate the action in most of those
movies those get incessant yeah but no I
I get what you mean like while you're
while you're watching it it's very
appealing and and at least for me I'm
you know you're always wanting to give
it to the benefit of the doubt but again
with all those things missing it just
loses the ability to be fun in any
superlative way or dramatic or intense
it's it's badass in moments if the
visuals are supporting that uh and and
that's the thing is like you know
again in the first part of the movie
you're sitting there going yeah this
could be derivative as hell but it's
part of the VIS like Zack Snyder's
vision is kind of the star that can make
all of that okay and and palatable
because of his enthusiasm and because
you could clearly tell like like this
dude should be writing a 100,000 graphic
novels where he could probably fully
always realize his vision yeah read like
a graphic novel too and and yeah and
through that perspective I'm happy to be
like ah you know that's fine you know as
long as the actors can sell the dialogue
but we're not watching a graphic but we
are watching a
movie and and ah yeah um so yeah anyway
guys what do you think about it though
is It ultimately satisfied are you going
be watching the director's cut are you
excited for Rebel Moon part two leave
your thoughts down below subscribe leave
a like
P all right job pick a name all right
let's do
Gabriel Gabriel do you know what you're
getting for Christmas what you are
getting this comment that what is it
John what did Gabriel say did you find
it I didn't but we're going to watch for
it in real time cuz we had to get into
this whole thing that you were like I
Gabriel left a comment and it was funny
and Gabriel gave us an Inkling as to
like where he is is based so like uh you
oh my god we'll get to it man I'm
getting I'm getting while the
getting we on Gabriel's time okay
Gabriel's so impatient Gabriel just
cannot stop hassling us at all times of
the day like I fight with Gabriel on The
Daily oh really is he a good fighter is
he you like to spar he's a he's a bit of
a [__] from fight I got admit man he
slaps that's messed up dude he's French
Canadian he says he's too nice to stop
pledging he's a French Canadian I was
worri about my my [__] fighting joke
but now you got to go even harder on
he's a slapper that French Canadian
freak yeah what are you going to do hit
me with a
maple
bag yeah while you you hang out with
your moose go use your hyp specific
accent yeah how's the ice skating going
around has a hockey coming along how's
public relations with other
Canadians that's a good question
actually Fair unfairly harsh on French
Canadians especially the French
Canadians yeah what do they ever do to
anybody maybe there French in there you
know did they come over and Conquer they
helped us out so like we're cool except
we always make fun of them for
surrendering all the time but otherwise
bunch of [__] than French those
French people B maybe they've been
really oppressive up in Canada who knows
they can take a joke which one the
French or the
Canadians French Canadians I don't know
I feel like nowadays no one could take a
joke but you know who can is Gabriel
Gabriel knows a good joke when he
Gabriel thank you for always being
understanding with us and for thank you
for being an atheists uh Happy Festivus
H what's that for the rest of us
apparently it's a thing that they
created on
Seinfeld or something what does that
mean it's like a it's like the surrogate
Christmas for atheists so it's like
here's a secular holiday that we can
pretty much do the same [__] around so
they just what do they celebrate not
believing in anything what a weird thing
to celebrate I guess they just celebrate
togetherness we're here today to honor
nothing yes we got a mass we went to
fist Church went to atheist church and
had a fist Mass yeah a candalite vigil
all right good for you um happy festive
this day hope you're chahwan hope you're
rolling your eyes at everyone's beliefs
this holiday season yes I hope you're
full down your nose at people and
judging them for believing in fantasies
hope you fold your arms during Christmas
dinner yeah yeah
refuse to participate I hope you shove
down your beliefs of science versus
religion yeah I hope you walk into a
church on Christmas day with just like a
dog ruined history ruined American and
Canadian culture so yeah
have fun ruining the holidays for
everyone yeah and not understanding that
no one really giv a [__] about the
religious side other than the religious
people yeah yeah maybe maybe we should
go to uh Christmas Mass for no so it is
long Serv I'm not going to say
boring it's just but that might
deliberately Pac be an emotion that
comes
up I would probably appreciate it more
now than I ever did in the times where
we really doing that before it would be
like oh man I'm going to be so tired and
I'm going to have to well I'm I'm going
to be like wow people really committed
but if I close my eyes I might be able
to get a good nap in I might be able to
talk to God on the
astroplane I went I took my grandma
in-law oh to church out here really I
think it was Palm Sunday or something
there was some one of them take church I
took her and I pay attention the whole
time entire time really enjoyed it I was
actually an admiration of everyone there
and it was like an extra long Mass was
like an hour and a half it was a foot
long yeah yeah it was a foot long mass
and then uh and then they decided to
have the exits be different than usual
where it's like one row at a time you
know how big that church is oh yeah so
that was like one row at a time and then
they had like an ex an encore outside I
was like okay now you're testing my
patience you my I thought we were ready
to go to the parking lot and leave now
we're outside of the church after an
already extended period more worship and
we are now here with cars passing by
listening to you
talk this is going on way too long man
I've been really respectful and kind
I've actually enjoyed it and taken away
some of the lessons the the overall
lessons so I had a good time no required
didn't need the wine and now we're here
no I got to go but we stayed and it was
fine oh anyway Gabriel you have to deal
with any of that yeah you don't have to
worry at all yeah enjoy that extra few
hours happy atheist day I hope I can
join you on it yeah peace
and
[Music]
objectivity